just you alone on a big Sound Stage for
three days men with leaf blowers House
of the Dragon has brought us a world
filled with Fantastical creatures
Monumental locations and Vivid
characters but how was this world
brought to life stick around to find out
more about what house of the Dragon
looked like without the VFX
well done that was great number one
seriously Hold On Tight hello guys
house of the Dragon actor Leo Ashton was
challenged with having to ride a dragon
at work on more than one occasion but
getting into this saddle wasn't going to
be a pony ride around the park the first
day was quite hard and the next star
came in I felt so much power and I was
like I need to get this this Dragon
moves like a giant mechanical bull
putting together this scene presented
several challenges including the moment
when the Dragon Goes vertical and Leo's
character needs to hang on from the
reins number two every tournament needs
an arena right and I said really Jim
have you got the money to build that and
he goes yeah yeah
the tournament took place not in a field
with some flags and a few onlookers
around it but in the depths of the city
surrounded by buildings and a colossal
Arena that reminds us of the real life
Coliseum for this a special structure
was created out of a large Dome and a
half moon shaped section of the Arena
while CGI was part of this most of it
was carefully built in real life number
three you can't CGI a soft Landing for a
stunt performer gravity works and hard
ground is hard when preparing the
grounds for the construction of the
Arena set while much of the scene was
created using CGI some things just
needed to be done for real when working
with horses you need soft ground and
stunt performers seem to like it too you
know what my horses to hurt themselves
you don't want to stunt men to hurt
themselves that meant before
construction could start on the arena an
area of land had to be heavily modified
leveled and carefully layered with the
right materials in order to accommodate
the horses and stunt performers who
would be working in the arena set number
four is this where we do science when we
look at this giant Construction in this
huge Warehouse we're reminded more of a
science facility at Nasa than a world of
dragons and drama even hearing the
production staff talk about this monster
sounds more like something from a Sci-Fi
it's that next evolution of the ability
to see your visual effects live in
camera
say that this is what the world of House
of the Dragon really looks like and
that's because this massive space is a
cylinder of imagination there are 2 000
video screens inside onto which the
background can be projected when filming
a scene this helps not only with
producing the amazing visuals of House
of the Dragon but it assists actors in
feeling more immersed in the action
which can make for an even better
performance number five
going nowhere fast ultimately on the set
there was just this unadorned bridge the
real-life location Dragonstone Bridge
might be impractical for filming but at
least it goes somewhere House of the
Dragon used a special technology to
capture and recreate a section of the
real-life location what we see is a long
and foggy Bridge with dragons that
circle around it what the actors see
might be similar thanks to the thousands
of video screens that surrounded this
set but the bridge only leads to the
other side of the giant room number six
Ahoy one third of this ship was actually
built for the filming of House of the
dragon and while CGI included The
Horizon the ocean and of course the
dragons there was actually a series of
fans that moved the sails and put a wind
effect onto the actor's hair and
costumes as well as a special water
cannon on set that would emulate waves
crashing against the side of the ship
and sending sea spray up into the air
and sometimes onto the actors on Deck
number seven duh doing it the simple way
might not sound like the most frequent
Choice when making House of the Dragon
but even this Fantastical production had
its exceptions Sometimes the best
solutions to a problem is the simplest
one in this scene where the CGI Dragon
swoops the deck of the ship the
challenge was to make it appear as
though the ship was tilting over
slightly in the water building a ship
was tricky enough and so for this scene
it was up to the actors to move together
as if they were losing their balance but
this isn't the first time we've seen
this kind of problem solving if you've
ever seen an episode of Star Trek this
group movement might be familiar to you
number eight gotcha it's understandable
that we might assume most of the ornate
and unusual things on screen in House of
the Dragon are created using CGI it's a
powerful tool and it gets used liberally
it does the trick of tricking us into
thinking we're looking at something real
but sometimes we get tricked twice the
collection of artifacts are rounding the
sea snake were actually made by a
talented and tricky team of set
decorators using Inspirations from
museums and the real world you would
take a treasure from each place and
that's what kind of became a big part of
his set and most of it was made from
insulation foam that had been carefully
carved and painted number nine they are
anything but two-dimensional filming
large crowd scenes with hundreds of
actors in costume and in character can
be a daunting task there are plenty of
considerations to be made and each take
can be a difficult one to coordinate
with the long list of details to follow
adding the restrictions that come with
filming during a pandemic didn't make
things any simpler with having 150
background performers on set the team
had to get creative so where we have to
put crowd into a shot that doesn't have
enough crowd in it they filmed some
sections of the crowd together and for
the rest they pulled each background
performer aside and got them to perform
a few actions in front of a green screen
the team then used computer Graphics to
fill out their rest of the crowd with
these card people number 10 when are we
we started shooting one year and we
finished a year later the claim your
dragon scene took seven months to film
and most of it was done on either end of
those seven months this this could be a
challenge for actor Leo Ashton who would
need to recall the details of his
performance after such a long time the
visual effects team was faced with the
challenge of concealing that Leo had
aged visibly and keeping this from being
apparent when cutting between takes
shots seven months apart number 11 from
hand drawing to computer graphics and
Back Again shooting on the Targaryen
Flagship found the production team
following what might seem like an odd
procedure first they designed the ship
then they animated it planned out the
actor and camera movements using
computer graphics and then they built
the ship only to start all over again by
shooting live actors on the ship set and
then going back and doing more CGI there
must have been a method to their Madness
because we think the end result is
fantastic number 12. my what a big
dragon you have one of the concepts of
the House of the Dragon series is that
dragons keep growing as they get older
when they are very young they can fit
comfortably perched on your shoulder as
they age they eventually become too
large to even fit through a door but
this dragon is something else vagar is
130 years old which means she's one big
dragon certainly the large Dragon you've
ever seen on Game of Thrones in fact
she's so big that she doesn't fit into
most places in her world anymore working
with an imaginary creature of that size
must have been hard to imagine but the
societal gives us an idea of just how
large this creature is meant to be
number 13. this might be the largest
dragon ever ridden on screen before with
the bigger dragon comes bigger movements
in order to make the riding the dragon
scene work the team had to design a
special saddle that would emulate the
movements of the dragon as well as
allowing actor Leo Ashton to ride on it
while performing the scene this
specially built machine was made to read
the pre-production visual sketches of
the scene and produced them as a sort of
mechanical bull ride this machine also
had to accurately re-perform each
movement in order to get multiple takes
of the scene without any mismatches
number four teen Point not taken while
the background and most of the crowd
might be added in later using the magic
of cinema this scene from the stadium
has an element of reality that everyone
on set could feel that day those horses
are real and those Riders are actually
jousting they used a few special pieces
of equipment and had a lot of training
of course stunt jousters use special
Lance is made of lightweight wood that
has been cut lengthwise along the
desired shatter point and painted to
look like they're solid while a
real-life jouster would aim for the body
of the opponent the stunt performers aim
to hit each other's Shields with the
special lances when they impact just
right the Lance breaks apart in an
impressive explosion of wood splinters
and with minimal impact to the stunt
performers number 15 it's not all CGI
with this show being so closely
connected to Game of Thrones the
production team set out to make the
audience feel like they were watching
the same show but it seems they also set
out to make the actors feel like they
were really in the world of House of the
Dragon you read the script at home and
you imagined the scene and then when you
come in it's always twice the size you
imagined it some of these wonderfully
crafted locations have been built from
the ground up by the production team but
others are Real historic places in life
House of the Dragon actor Eve best said
you walk around these sets that look
like ancient monuments and buildings
with massive statues or you can be on
these amazing locations you cannot
believe that this is on the earth
somewhere this extraordinary while the
visual effects team says they held back
this season we think they are off to a
strong start the sets seem to be just as
impressive as the in-show locations
which house of the Dragon location real
or VFX would you like to visit most let
us know in the comments below
foreign